fewer than speaking of opportunity of a
lifetime fewer than a dozen people have
ever held the title of White House
photographer David Valdez served in that
position under President George Herbert
Walker Bush he says he visited all 50
states in 75 countries with the
president Valdez witnessed history and
forged a lifelong friendship with mr.
Bush now he shares his thoughts
impressions and of course photographs
when he was getting ready to run for
president
Life magazine wanted to send a
photographer up to take some pictures of
him and I talked to Barbara Bush about
it and she said well you ought to just
come over 6 o'clock in the morning in
the next morning and see what happens so
I go up there and a few minutes later
the grandchildren started coming in with
all the accomplishments and things that
President Bush did he was most proud of
being called a husband a father and a
grandfather a few hours before the
beginning of the Gulf War
he went walking on the South Lawn and
I'd get a photo of him he was just
thinking about sending young men and
women off to war he would go jogging in
the morning and maybe play around at
tennis and then go play golf and then go
boating and then kind of end the day
with a round of horseshoes the press
corps would just be dragging behind him
because he would do that in rain or
shine mrs. Bush always certainly
protected him there was a true love
affair you'd always see them holding
hands or patting each other on the back
or just making sure that each one of
them was ok working for President Bush
changed my life forever having that
opportunity to work with him and see him
and especially how he loved and
interacted with his family it's a real
end of an era and I'm real sad about it
the White House photographer always has
a front row seat to what's going on in
the family and it's so good to see the
pictures come to life you know you take
it at the time you think no big deal and
you look back years later and it means
so much I mean hey there are they're
there for every moment
yes nicely nicely done fewer then
speaking of opportunity of a lifetime
fewer than a dozen people have ever held
the title of White House photographer
David Valdes served in that position
under President George Herbert Walker
Bush he says he visited all 50 states in
75 countries with the president Valdez
witnessed history and forged a lifelong
friendship with mr. Bush now he shares
his thoughts impressions and of course
photographs when he was getting ready to
run for president
Life magazine wanted to send a
photographer up to take some pictures of
him and I talked to Barbara Bush about
it and she said well you ought to just
come over six o'clock in the morning in
the next morning and see what happens so
I go up there and a few minutes later
the grandchildren started coming in with
all the accomplishments and things that
President Bush did he was most proud of
being called a husband a father and a
grandfather a few hours before the
beginning of the Gulf War
he went walking on the South Lawn and I
got a photo of him he was just thinking
about sending young men and women off to
war he would go jogging in the morning
and maybe play around at tennis and then
go play golf and then go boating and
then kind of end the day with a round of
horseshoes the press corps would just be
dragging behind him because he would do
that in rain or shine mrs. Bush always
certainly protected him there was a true
love affair you'd always see them
holding hands or patting each other on
the back or just making sure that each
one of them was okay working for
President Bush changed my life forever
having that opportunity to work with him
and see him and especially how he loved
and interacted with his family it's a
real end of an era and I'm real sad
about it the White House photographer
always has a front row seat to what's
going on in the family and it's so good
to see the pictures come to life you
know you take it at the time you think
no big deal and you look back years
later and it means so much I mean a
there
they're there for every moment yes
nicely nicely done